y
[Música]
ah
continúa en nicaragua los arrestos y
persecución contra opositores actos que
ya suman 18 detenidos en las últimas dos
semanas la más reciente detención es la
del periodista y aspirante a la
presidencia miguel mora crece la
preocupación de los familiares de los
detenidos porque las autoridades no les
han permitido verlos ni conocer su
condición aspirantes a la presidencia
líderes opositores empresarios banqueros
y hasta ex guerrilleros que una vez
formaron parte del partido sandinista se
suman a la lista de más de 120 presos
políticos según la oposición pero el
gobierno los acusa de pedir intervención
extranjera y financiar un golpe de
estado en nicaragua todos son
abiertamente críticos a ortega la oea la
unión europea y varios gobiernos del
mundo piden la liberación de estos
opositores pero nicaragua reclama no
injerencia méxico y argentina llamaron a
consultas a sus embajadores en medio del
aumento de las tensiones los arrestos
que le traen nuevas sanciones
internacionales al círculo cercano de
daniel ortega quien se prepara para
reelegirse por cuarta ocasión
[Música]
en venezuela hay 300 son presos
políticos según el último balance de la
ong de derechos humanos foro penal la
lista ha sido certificada por la
organización de estados américanos del
total 130 son militares y hay un
adolescente el resto son civiles muchos
de los detenidos han sido acusados por
el gobierno de nicolas maduros de
conspiración para derrocarlo por lo
penal también habla de arrestos
motivados por publicaciones en redes
sociales o por ejercer el periodismo un
caso emblemático es el del ex diputado
juan requesens acusado de intentar
presuntamente asesinar en 2018 al
presidente nicolás maduro
el parlamentario pasó dos años
encarcelados y hoy está bajo arresto
domiciliario además de los presos
políticos más de 9.000 personas siguen
sujetas a medidas restrictivas de
libertad
maduro insiste en que no son presos
políticos sino políticos presos aunque
en momentos de negociación política
entre gobierno y oposición éstos se han
convertido en fichas de carne
[Música]
biólogo si acumula más de 400 presos
políticos y la más famosa es mariah
kolésnikova la disidente política de 39
años que rompió su pasaporte eligiendo
así la prisión antes que el exilio
también sigue preso sergei tejanos y el
marido de svetlana tejanos acá ya él era
el candidato opositor pero su arresto
hizo que fuese ella la que pasase a
liderar a la disidencia la oposición
reivindica que fue ella la que ganó las
elecciones pero desde el año pasado el
número de presos políticos en
bielorrusia se ha disparado hasta 436
según el centro de derechos humanos
viasna cientos más están siendo
investigados en algunos casos todo acaba
en tragedia como aquel joven de 18 años
acusado de instigar a disturbios masivos
que se suicidó culpando al comité de
investigación del país otro que fue
presionado para autoinculparse se hizo
una herida en el cuello en pleno juicio
el régimen bielorruso ha plantado cara
al descontento con todos los medios
también con el judicial se piden hasta
tres años de prisión por acudir a una
manifestación no autorizada los últimos
en carne detenidos han sido román
protosevich y sofía esa pega cuyo avión
fue forzado a aterrizar por las
autoridades bielorrusas cuando se
dirigía a lituania
[Música]